[Music]
Doja cat dropping Jaws in her Paris
fashion week look it's crazy yeah Doja
stepped out to the scalparelli show in
head to toe sparkling red gems
[Music]
she was covered with 30 000 hand placed
Swarovski crystals all brought to life
by celeb makeup artist Pat McGrath
[Music]
check out doja's nearly five hour
transformation The Red Hot look was
dubbed doja's Inferno sure to stand out
amongst the crowd it's not too crazy
while Doja rocked the attention-grabbing
look it's not the first time she's gone
for a daring style I'm obsessed Doja
turned heads with her eclectic wardrobe
at the Vivian Westwood show last October
and after donning this Bohemian style
fit she opted for a new look this time
with face paint and Drawn On full length
gloves it's giving face and that's it
another face-giving moment Dojo sporting
this statement makeup look covered in
metallic gold and Last Summer the star
shocked fans when she debuted a fully
buzzed head and shaved off her eyebrows
I feel like I I was never supposed to
have hair anyway
I don't like having hair
I never liked having hair
I cannot tell you one time since the
beginning of my life that I've ever been
like
it's cool
I just do not like to have hair if there
is one thing we know doja's not afraid
to go bold when it comes to Fashion
that's everything that I care about
[Music]
thank you